[Music]  looking for some life hacks oh we got  you covered look at this  i work with plants for a living and i'm  here to tell you you have the magical  powers to know when any type of plant  needs to be watered  get ready here's your magical power  your finger  stick your finger about this deep in any  plant if you take it out and you see  dirt on it don't water don't do it  over watering kills plants now if you  stick your finger in and it looks more  like this it's time if you get your  plant completely bone dry like this it  might get sad but when you water this  it'll bounce back if you over water it  it will not come back say it with me  underwatering is better than over  watering  under watering is better than  over watering i live for tips  [Music]  you